สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนกลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนนะ
ครับในช่องเจอที่ไหน
วันนี้ครูอาร์ตี้ข้างหลังสีเหลืองเป็นสี
เหลือง
มีเป็นลายสีเหลืองนะ
คะวันนี้วันนี้เราเจอกันวันเสาร์ครับวัน
นี้เราไม่ได้เจอกันวันจันทร์
เจอกันวันเสาร์นะ
เราไม่ได้เจอกันวันจันทร์เพราะอะไรเพราะ
ว่าครูเอ๋ไม่ว่างวันจันทร์อ๋อวันจันทร์
ไม่ว่างก็เลยมาวันนี้
วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 25 ครับ
วันนี้
อะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนมีนาคมครับเดือน
มีนาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ครับ
ปีคศ
นะคะและนี้ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
เวลา 4 โมง 5 นาที 4 โมง 5 นาทีโอเค
[เพลง]
นะคะ 4 โมงเย็นกับอีก 5 นาที
นะคะ
เย้อะไร
ดีใจได้เจอวันอื่น
ใช่อ้าววันนี้สิ่งที่เราจะมา
คุยกันนะครับเราจะคุยกันเรื่อง
อยากจะแนะนำอะไรให้นักเรียนรู้นะอยากจะ
แนะนำ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ว่าอะไรจะเดาว่าอะไร
ว่าครูอาร์ตี้เนี่ยอยากจะแนะนำ
อะไร
1 อย่างแต่หลายๆอย่าง
ที่ที่คนไทยคนไทยชอบไปแล้วคนไทยก็ชอบไป
ว่า
[เพลง]
พระพุทธรูปนะคะ
ที่ประเทศไทยมีพระพุทธรูปมากๆไหมคะง่าย
ที่ประเทศไทยมีพระพุทธรูปมากๆมีพระ
พุทธรูปหลายๆองค์
[เพลง]
การหรือเราพูดว่าเยอะมากนะคะว่า
ทำไมทำไมเราถึงมีพุทธรูป
มีพระพุทธรูปเหรอคะลูกมีไว้เพื่ออะไร
เพื่ออะไร
มีไว้เพื่อ
เพื่อให้เหตุผลน่ะมีหลายๆเหตุผลอย่าง
หนึ่งนะคะก็คือว่าคนไทยเรา
ส่วนใหญ่ส่วนใหญ่เนาะส่วนใหญ่ใช่ครับส่วน
ใหญ่นะคะศาสนาพุทธนะคะเรานับถือศาสนาพุทธ
เราก็จะไหว้พระนะคะก็จะไหว้พระพุทธรูป
ไหว้พระธรรมแล้วก็ไหว้พระสงฆ์นะคะแต่วัน
นี้เราจะพูดพระพุทธรูป
เพราะว่าพระพุทธรูปเป็นเป็นสิ่งที่ทำให้
เราคิดถึงเป็นตัวแทนทำให้เราคิดถึงพระ
พุทธเจ้าคิดถึงใครนะคิดถึงพระพุทธเจ้า
พระพุทธเจ้าเป็นใคร
พระพุทธเจ้า
ตอนแรกเนี่ยพระพุทธเจ้าก็เป็นเป็นคนที่
ที่รู้รู้เรื่องการจันศาสนาพุทธ
ตอนนี้พระพุทธเจ้าไม่อยู่แล้ว
ทำให้เราเนี่ยก็ไม่เคยไม่เห็นพระพุทธเจ้า
ใช่ไหมเราก็เลยต้องมีพระพุทธรูปเป็นตัว
แทนเป็นตัวแทนพระพุทธเจ้าเวลาเราอยากจะ
ไหว้พระพุทธเจ้าเราจะไม่เรียกว่าเนาะกราบ
ไหว้
กราบพระพุทธเจ้าเราก็จะกราบพระพุทธรูปแทน
นะคะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนอาจจะสงสัยนะครับว่าเอ๊ะ
ทำไมทำไมมีพระพุทธรูปหลายๆองค์มีพระ
พุทธรูปไม่มีมีชื่อมีชื่อไม่เหมือนกัน
ด้วย
อ๋อพระพุทธรูปไม่ได้ชื่อพระพุทธเจ้า
เป็นตัวแทนพระพุทธเจ้าจากว่าไม่เวลาปั้น
ใช่ไหมคะ
แบบหล่อ
แล้วก็ก็แต่ซึ่งๆคนเราเรียกว่าสร้างพระ
เนาะความสร้างพระพุทธรูป
มีการสร้างพระมานานมากนักเรียนมากกว่า 700
ปีนะ
คะ
มากกว่า 700 ปีมีการสร้างพระพุทธรูปขึ้น
มาในประเทศไทยนะคะดังนั้นเนี่ยการสร้างใน
แต่ละผ้าไหมนะคะก็จะทำให้มีพระที่ลักษณะ
แตกต่างกันแตกต่างก็คือไม่เหมือนกัน
เหมือนกัน
ก็เลยต้องมีชื่อด้วยใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับก็จะ
มีชื่อที่ไม่เหมือนกันแต่เป็นเป็นตัวแทน
ของพระพุทธเจ้าเหมือนกัน
วันนี้ครูอาร์ตี้ก็คือจะแนะนำพระพุทธรูป
สมัยต่างๆที่จะบอกว่าชื่ออะไรใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับเป็นพระพุทธรูปที่คนไทยรู้จักคนไทย
นิยมไปกราบไหว้กัน
นะ
แนะนำพระพุทธรูปองค์แรกองค์แรกที่ถ้าครัว
ที่บอกชื่อเนี่ยพวกเอกก็ต้องรู้จักนัก
เรียนน่าจะเคยไปกราบไหว้แล้วด้วยวันนี้จะ
บอกชื่อก่อนหรือจะให้ดูรูปก่อน
อ่าเดี๋ยวโคโยตี้ให้ดูวัดก่อนอ้าวว่าพระ
พุทธรูปองค์นี้อยู่วัดนะ
จะบอกว่าอยู่ที่วัดไหนจังหวัดอะไรด้วยนะ
เผื่อนักเรียนมาเหนื่อยนักเรียนมาเที่ยว
ประเทศไทยจะได้รู้ว่าเอ๊ะไปวัดไหนจังหวัด
อะไรมีพระพุทธรูปอะไรได้ค่ะ
องค์แรกวัดแรกเลยค่ะวัดวัดอะไรคะที่นี่
ครับ
นักเรียนนักเรียนหลายๆคนก็ร้องอ๋อแล้วตอน
นี้
[เพลง]
ชื่ออะไรคะครูอาร์ตี้วัดนี้ชื่อวัด
ชื่อเต็มๆก่อนไหมเอาชื่อเต็มๆ
พระ
ศรีรัตนศาสดารามกูชื่อยาวมาก
[เพลง]
พูดไม่ได้
เวลาเล่นเรียกแท็กซี่แบบแท็กซี่ไปวัดพระ
ศรีรัตนศาสดารามแท็กซี่จากเก่าหัวไหมงง
เลยใช่ไหม
นักเรียนก็จะรู้รู้จักชื่อพระด้วย
[เพลง]
พระที่วัดนี้นะคะพระพุทธรูปนะคะพระ
พุทธรูปที่วัดนี้
นักเรียนคิดว่าสีอะไรก่อน
นักเรียนนักเรียนเห็นวัดไหมคะอ่ะ
ได้ไหมคะเจดีย์อยู่นี่ครับเจดีย์เนี่ยสี
ทองนะคะหลังคาข้างๆเจดีย์หลังคาตรงนู้น
สีน้ำเงินนะ
สีอะไร
สีเขียวครับโอเคงั้นเราก็จะมี a สีทอง B
สีน้ำเงินสีเขียว
นักเรียนคะนักเรียนฟังถึงตรงนี้นะคะนัก
เรียนคิด
คิดหน่อยคิดนะคะแล้ว comment ข้างล่างพระ
พุทธ
ให้นักเรียนรอนักเรียน comment นิดนึง
ครัวตี้คิดว่านักเรียนหลายคนรู้นะรู้แล้ว
ใช่ไหมเคยมานักเรียนก็จะตอบว่า
สีสี
เขียวใช่ไหมนักเรียนมีใครตอบถูกไหมสี
เขียวนะคะ
นี่ครับ
นี่มีสีเขียวใช่ไหม
แต่ว่า
เครื่องทรงเราเนี่ยเครื่องทรงก็คือตรงนี้
นะครับซึ่งส่งเครื่องส่งตรงนี้สีทองนะคะ
เป็นสีทอง
แต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยเป็นพระ
พุทธรูปองค์เดียวนะองค์เดียวอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ตอนที่หน้าร้อนฤดูร้อนตอนนี้เลยตอนนี้เลย
ใช่ครับ
จุดที่ 1 ใส่ฤดูร้อนนะครับ
ข้างล่างข้างล่างข้างล่าง
[เพลง]
ขอบคุณค่ะ
ชุดที่ 2 ใส่ตอนไหนคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ประเทศไทยมี 3 ฤดูร้อน
พระสีเขียวเนี่ยนะคะก็จะมีชุด 3 ชุด
เปลี่ยนทุกฤดูครูแอนตี้เราพูด pass สี
เขียวพระชื่ออะไรคะชื่ออะไรยังไม่ได้บอก
เลยใช่ไหมชื่อ
แก้วครับหรือที่คนไทยที่รู้จักกันว่าอยู่
ที่วัดวัดพระแก้ว
[เพลง]
เป็นชื่อเล่นนะ
หรือพระแก้วมรกตนะคะคนไทยจะพูดพระแก้ว
มรกตแต่พระรูปนี้ไม่ได้ทำจากมรกต
นะคะ
[เพลง]
ทำจากหยกค่ะ
สีเขียวเหมือนกันนะคะ
แต่ชื่อพระแก้วมรกต
นักเรียนต้องรู้จักแน่ๆเลย
ต้องเคยเห็นแน่ๆแต่อาจจะเคยเห็นไม่รู้ว่า
ถ้านักเรียนมาตอนหน้าร้อนนักเรียนก็จะ
เห็นแบบนี้ถ้ามาตอนหน้าฝนฤดูฝนก็จะเห็น
แบบนี้
ดูหนาวก็จะเห็นแบบนี้องค์เดียวกันนะครับ
โอเคอันนี้ก็คือพระพุทธรูปองค์ที่ 1 ที่
มาแนะนำให้นักเรียนรู้จักก็อยู่ที่
กรุงเทพฯนะคะกรุงเทพฯครับ
เดี๋ยวไปองค์ที่ 2 กันครับจังหวัดอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
เหมือนกัน
สวยมาก
ๆสวยมากๆ
จังหวัดนี้
คนยิ้มมากๆ
เป็นเมืองเก่าคนไทยยิ้มทั้งประเทศครับ
[เพลง]
ได้ครับองค์นี้ครับ
ไม่ใช่สุโขทัยพิษณุโลกควรที่จำผิดจำผิด
อยู่พิษณุโลก
จริงๆครูอาร์ตี้จะไม่ผิดค่ะ
คืออย่างนี้
สุโขทัยใช่ไหมคะสุโขทัยพิษณุโลกเป็นของ
สุโขทัย
สมัยยังไม่มีอยุธยายังไม่มีกรุงเทพฯก็
สุโขทัยและพิษณุโลกอยู่ในสุโขทัยเป็นของ
สุโขทัย
[เพลง]
ที่ไม่เหมือนไม่เหมือนพระพุทธรูปองค์อื่น
ๆเลยก็คือมีตรงนี้ครับ
ตรงนี้
ครัวที่วาดได้ไหมอ่ะจะเป็นการรบกวนไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ตรงนี้ครับตรงนี้
ตรงนี้
เราเรียกว่าเรือนแก้วครับมีเรือนแก้ว
มีเรือนแก้วอยู่จะไม่เหมือนพระพุทธรูป
องค์อื่น
เป็นพระพุทธรูปที่มีความสวยงามมากที่สุด
นะครับ
หมายถึงว่าคือต้องบอกนักเรียนก่อนนะคะว่า
เป็นพระพุทธรูปที่สร้างขึ้น
ก่อนแต่นักเรียนอาจจะเห็นแบบนี้ที่มีคน
เอาไปทำเหมือนเหมือนองค์เล็กๆหรืออะไรนะ
คะใช่
มาจากตรงนี้เลียนแบบเหมือนๆกันองค์ที่
เล็กกว่าค่ะก็เรียกว่าพระพุทธชินราชนะ
ครับ
รู้สึกยังไงคะ
เข้าไปข้างในข้างในโบสถ์ข้างในโบสถ์พระ
พุทธชินราชอยู่ในโบสถ์เข้าไปในโบสถ์มี
ความรู้สึกเย็นสบายมากแล้วก็มีความ
อธิบายไม่ได้รู้สึก
เย็นสบายครับรู้สึกสบายคืออะไรที่รู้สึก
ไม่สบายใจหรืออะไรที่อยู่ในหัว
หมดเลย
นะหลายๆคนน่ะอย่างครูเอ๋เนี่ยเข้าไปดู
ปั๊บครูเอ๋ก็จะแบบ
ด้วยความ
เรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะ
ช่างอ่ะเนาะช่างอ่ะที่เขาสร้างองค์พระ
ขึ้นมาก็งดงามต้องเรียกว่าสวยอย่างเดียว
นะคะนักเรียนต้องเรียกว่างดงามคือมากกว่า
สวยแล้วก็โบสถ์ก็มีมีลายอ่า
เป็นลายสวยงามเหมือนกันนะครับคือทั้งหมด
อ่ะพอเราเข้าไปนั่งปั๊บเนี่ยความรู้สึก
ของเราก็คือว่า
อากาศข้างนอกอ่ะร้อนแต่ตรงนี้เรารู้สึก
เย็นจังเลยอ่ะข้างในโบสถ์จะเย็น
รู้สึกดีมากนะคะใช่ไหม
ใช่ๆเป็นความรู้สึกสบายเย็นสบายปลอดภัยมี
ความสุขนะครับมีความสุขไม่
[เพลง]
มีอะไรร้อนใจใช่ๆๆความสบายแบบนั้นครับ
เราก็อธิบายไม่ถูก
เอาว่าเราไปแล้วเราสบายใจโอเครู้สึกสบาย
มีความสุขแบบสบายๆนะครับ
[เพลง]
มีขนาดมีขนาดความกว้าง
กว้าง
2 เมตร
หมายถึงว่าความกว้างจากตรงนี้ครับใช่ครับ
ของฐาน
2 เมตร 50
[เพลง]
คนไทยเนี่ยจะคิดว่าถ้าเป็นเกี่ยวกับพระ
พุทธรูปเราจะเคารพเราก็ไม่ควรจะไปทำอะไร
ที่ไม่มีหรือว่าไม่สุภาพไม่เรียบร้อยบน
นั้น
นานเกินไปเดี๋ยวนักเรียนอาจจะอยากรู้แล้ว
ว่าองค์ที่ 3 เนี่ยเป็น
อยู่จังหวัดไหนใช่ไหม
ว่าสร้างสร้างใกล้ๆกัน
อ่าอยู่ที่นี่ครับอยู่ที่นี่ครับ
จำผิดหรือเปล่าว่าสร้างใกล้ๆกัน
นี่คือใช่ครับพระพุทธสิหิงค์
เนี่ยมีอยู่ 3 ที่
แต่เป็นพระพุทธสิหิงค์เหมือนกัน
เป็นพระพุทธสิหิงค์เหมือนกัน
แต่ที่ที่ครูอาร์ตี้เอามาให้ดูอยู่ที่
เชียงใหม่ครับ
เชียงใหม่เลยอยู่ในเมืองเชียงใหม่เลยเวลา
ไปเที่ยวไปเดินเล่นในถนนคนเดินจริงก็จะ
อยู่ใกล้ๆวัดนี้
[เพลง]
แล้วก็สวยด้วยสวย
ที่วัดนี้มีพระพุทธรูปชื่อพระพุทธสิหิงค์
พระพุทธเจ้า
พระพุทธสิหิงค์องค์นี้ชื่อคล้ายๆกันเนาะ
พระพุทธชินราชพระพุทธสิหิงค์
ว่าอะไรนะ
เขาสร้างใกล้ๆ
ใกล้ๆกันเลยใช่ไหมคะในยุคสมัยนั้น
องค์นี้สร้างเดี๋ยวนะ
ครับ
เราลืมประวัติของพระพุทธสิหิงค์จะงานมาก
เพราะว่าตั้งแต่ตอนนั้นยังไม่มี
ก็เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนย้ายเมืองหลวงมีการทำ
สงครามกับพม่ามีการรบกันแล้วก็ย้ายพระ
พุทธรูปไปตามที่ต่างๆค่ะ
เดินทางไปหลายที่
ไปเชียงใหม่ไปอยู่อยุธยาไปอยู่
นครศรีธรรมราชกลับมาอยู่เชียงใหม่แล้วไป
แล้วก็สุดท้ายมาอยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯทั้งๆที่
เชียงใหม่ก็จะสร้างพระพุทธสิหิงค์เอาไว้
ที่นครศรีธรรมราชตอนที่ตอนที่ไปอยู่ที่
นครศรีธรรมราชก็สร้างพระพุทธศาสนาไว้ที่
นครศรีธรรมราชอ๋อหมายความว่าองค์จริง
เนี่ยองค์จริงเนี่ยมีการเดินทาง
ได้เรื่อยๆก็เวลาเดินทางไปอยู่ที่ไหนแล้ว
ออกจากที่นั่นคนที่นั่นก็จะสร้างองค์
จำลอง
อยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมปัจจุบันอยู่กรุงเทพฯ
อยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่ครับ
ตอนสมัยรัชกาลที่ 1 ครับพระพุทธยอดฟ้า
จุฬาโลกขึ้นครองราชย์ก็ส่งย้ายมาไว้ที่
กรุงเทพฯ
[เพลง]
อันนี้อยู่กรุงเทพฯนะ
ที่นั่งพูดไทยสวรรค์ใช่ครับพระราชวัง
บวรสถานมงคล
กรุงเทพฯ
ไม่ได้หยุด
แต่ว่าเราก็เราก็จะไม่ได้มีโอกาสเข้าไป
บ่อยๆไงครับเพราะฉะนั้นคนไทยที่จะไปกราบ
ไหว้พระพุทธศาสนาก็อาจจะไปที่เชียงใหม่
หรือไปที่นครศรีธรรมราชกันดีกว่า
ไม่มีโอกาสเขาไม่ได้เปิดให้เข้าไปบ่อยๆ
ใช่งั้นก็ดูองค์จำลองนะคะ
[เพลง]
อ๋อใช่ๆๆ
ในแต่ละปี
ตอนสงกรานต์
[เพลง]
เราจะได้เห็นพระพุทธศาสนาตอนสงกรานต์
เพราะว่าจะมีเชิญออกมานะคะสำหรับรดน้ำนะ
คะ
[เพลง]
ก็สงกรานต์ก็จะ 1 ปี 1 ครั้งที่จะเชิญพระ
พุทธสิหิงค์ออกมาข้างนอกนะคะ
ตามข่าวถ้าอยากจะเห็นพระพุทธสิหิงค์
แต่ถ้าแต่ถ้ามาแล้วอยากจะเห็นเลยไม่ต้อง
รอสงกรานต์ก็ไปที่เชียงใหม่หรือไปที่
นครศรีธรรมราชใช่ค่ะโอเค
เดี๋ยวไปดูองค์ต่อไปครับองค์ต่อไปอีกองค์
นึงอีกองค์หนึ่ง
ติดแม่น้ำเหมือนกันแต่อยู่ภาคตะวันออกภาค
ตะวันออก
วัดนี้ค่ะ
บางปะกงนะครับทุกคนที่บ้านครูเอ๋เนี่ยชอบ
วัดนี้
อยู่ใกล้กรุงเทพฯใช่มั้ยคะ
จังหวัดอะไรก่อนดีกว่าจังหวัดอะไรก่อน
จังหวัดอะไร
วัดชื่ออะไรคะวัดชื่อ
จริง
แม่น้ำแม่น้ำชื่ออะไรคะแม่น้ำข้างหลังแม่
น้ำข้างหลังเป็นแม่น้ำบางปะกงครับ
แล้วจริงๆวัดชื่ออะไรอ่ะเพราะว่าคนไทยแบบ
คนไทยอ่ะจะเรียกชื่อวัดตามชื่อของพระ
ชื่อวัดชื่อเดียวกันครับแต่ว่าชื่อวัด
โสธรวรารามวิหาร
เรียกว่าวัดหลวงพ่อโสธร
อยู่ที่วัดนั้น
ชื่อเดียวกันกับชื่อวัดชื่อหลวงพ่อนะครับ
อยากจะเห็นหลวงพ่อโสธรค่ะหลวงพ่อโสธรนี่
ครับหลวงพ่อโสธร
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ลักษณะของหลวงพ่อโสธรคือตามที่ครูอาร์ตี้
เอามาให้ดูแต่คุณไปเจอคลิปที่พูดเกี่ยว
กับหลวงพ่อโสธร
แล้วก็ตอนนี้เลยไม่รู้ว่าองค์ไหนองค์จริง
เพราะว่าบางคนก็บอกว่าองค์นี้องค์จริงแต่
บางคนก็บอกว่าองค์จริงอยู่อีกที่นึงที่
วัดนั่นแหละบางคนก็บอกว่า
องค์จริงอยู่ข้างในแล้วมีองค์จำลองทับ
อยู่องค์จริงอยู่
แต่ว่ากลัวตี้ไปกลัวตี้ก็ไหว้องค์ที่เด่น
ที่สุด
ตรงหน้าที่
เพราะว่าจะสังเกตว่านักเรียนจะทำไมมีพระ 2
องค์
ก็คือมีองค์จำลองนั่นแหละค่ะ
ก็ยังไม่ทราบว่าองค์ไหนนะคะ
ไม่ได้องค์ใหญ่มาก
[เพลง]
พ่อก็องค์ใหญ่สิก็องค์ใหญ่กว้างเมตร 50
สูงเท่าคนยืน
[เพลง]
เคยไปแค่ 2 ครั้งนักเรียน
แต่คุณแม่พี่สาวครูเอ๋เนี่ยไปบ่อยๆใช่ไหม
ใช่เพราะว่าเป็นพระที่คนไทยก็เคารพนะครับ
แล้วก็นิยมไปไหว้บูชากันนะครับ
[เพลง]
ต้องบอกว่า
บางคนน่ะที่แต่งงานแล้ว
แล้วไม่มีลูก
ไม่มีลูกอ่ะอยากจะมีลูกบางคนก็ไปไหว้หลวง
พ่อโสธรแล้วก็ขอลูกขอให้มีลูกนะครับ
อันนี้คนไทยก็เชื่อ
[เพลง]
จริงๆพระพุทธรูปแต่ละองค์นะแต่ละองค์ก็คน
ไทยก็มักจะไปขอขอสิ่งนั้นขอสิ่งนี้กัน
บ่อยๆเป็นความเชื่อเป็นความเชื่อส่วนตัว
ของแต่ละคนนะ
ได้ยินนะคะได้ยินนักเรียนจริงไม่จริงก็
ต้องคิดนะคะว่าจริง
วันนี้เราก็แนะนำให้รู้จักกันนะครับทั้ง
หมดกี่รูปครับ 4 รูปใช่ไหมค่ะก็มีหลวงพ่อ
โสธรมีหลวงพ่อโสธรมี
[เพลง]
ถิ่นราชพระพุทธชินราชนะคะพระองค์แรกก็คือ
พระแก้วมรกต
[เพลง]
เดี๋ยวมีอะไรเราคอยติดตามกันว่าเราจะมา
เล่าเรื่องอะไรที่เกี่ยวข้องกับพระ
พุทธศาสนาให้ฟังกันอีกนิดนึงได้ไหมคะ
ถามว่านักเรียนเคยไปไหว้เคยเคยไปกราบ
อะไรก็ได้
ที่
พระพุทธรูปองค์ไหนคะเคยไปดูเคยไปเที่ยว
เคยไปถ่ายรูปนะคะเคยไปกราบพระพุทธรูปองค์
ไหนในสี่องค์นี้เคยไหมมีใครเคยกลัวที่คิด
ว่านักเรียนส่วนใหญ่ต้องเคยไปกราบแก้ว
มรกต
โอเคค่ะงั้นเราไปกันได้แล้วค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
เราสองคนลาไปก่อนแล้วครับสวัสดีครับพี่
เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย